hey guys now most of you know that i've
lost two brothers
i've also lost my dad and recently just
a couple of weeks ago
i also lost my father-in-law
my wife and i are very sad and it is
very hard at these times
in life when you have to lose a loved
one
but there's also some beauty in it
because you grow from it and you learn
there are two very important things that
i learned the first thing is that
you have to appreciate the people that
are still in your life
your friends and your family because you
never know
when their time here on earth might be
finished
and they might die the second thing that
i learned is that you have to enjoy your
life you yourself should not waste your
life
it's a gift and you should live it to
the fullest
so to help you and myself to do it
i've written down a list of 20 bucket
list ideas
that you gotta try this is going to be
interesting video so
let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
just very quick if you're new to my
channel and haven't subscribed yet then
please
consider it alright guys here we go
let's start with the bucket list
survive in the wilderness live up the
land for a full
week you got to do this at least once in
your life
make a fire and find the food yourself
all alone for
one full week or if you don't like being
alone
then just do it with a couple of friends
you won't regret it
go on a real safari drive in africa
if you have the opportunity to do it go
for it
see and experience what the world was
really
like before humankind killed most of the
animals
[Music]
even better sleep over in a game park to
get a full
experience
go and see all the seven wonders
of the world you have to go and see it
and experience it
for yourself the great wall of china
which is 4 000 miles long
the world's longest man-made structure
cries the redeemer statue in brazil the
130-foot
icon of rio de janeiro machu picchu
in peru the amazing city of the incas
on the andean peaks petra in jordan
which is like a small city carved into
stone
the capital of the nabataean empire
the taj mahal in india the white marble
mausoleum commissioned for the wife of
mogul emperor
shah jahan chaizan itza in mexico
the powerful ancient city of the mayan
civilization the roman colosseum in rome
built between 70 and 80 a.d used for
500 years by the romans for gladiator
events
battle reenactments animal hunts and
executions
go scuba diving there is a whole world
under the sea far away from the city
noise and other humans
just you and nature all the amazing
underwater
life it's something you've got to do
start your own business give it a shot
what do you have to lose what's the
worst that can happen
the worst is just you fail and that's it
creating your own company or business
gives you a lot of freedom
purpose and pride you don't have to do
it full time
just do it on the side go
skydiving now i know for a lot of people
this is a no-no
because they don't like heights right
but if it doesn't bother you
go for it the view is stunning and it is
an experience
that you will never forget
catch a marlin go deep sea fishing
and catch the trophy of them all the
marlin
or if you've never gone fishing you
gotta catch at least
one fish on the big ocean one fish in a
lake
and one fish in the river but just one
tip here
if you go and you've never fished before
go with someone that actually
knows what they're doing because then
you'll catch some fish
and you'll enjoy get an old-fashioned
hot razor shave at a barber shop now i
know
it might sound strange to you if you've
never done it before but it's better
than you think you've got to do it at
least once in your life
collect something that you love
something
that you're passionate about like old
money
wine stamps or antiques it is honestly a
lot of fun especially when you start to
trade and
when you can actually start to make some
money off of it
spoil your parents surprise them for
all paid wicking away or take them to
dinner and pay
for everything and it needs to be a
surprise
something they won't ever expect from
you
they looked after you for years so the
least
you can do is to say thank you
get a good body you gotta have
a good healthy fat body at least once
in your life start to work out and eat
healthy you will live longer
have more energy feel better develop
self-control
self-discipline and hopefully then
you'll realize that it's just better to
always
stay healthy and fit
donate anonymously give money to someone
that really needs it but they should not
know
that it was you neither should anyone
else
don't be like those kind of people that
just want to give away money
so that they can look good and brag
about it
just knowing you made a difference in
someone's life
is reward enough
go to any world cup match choose the
sport you like
rugby football or soccer cricket the
olympics
or any other sport that feeling of the
crowd
cheering in your team that's just about
to score a point
there's nothing like it
become a father it's very easy
for most men just to become a father but
it's very
difficult to become a great dad
a dad that will raise your child to
become an amazing
human being being a dad will change
your life
sharkage diving yes swim with the sharks
and see them
close up the only thing between you and
death
is the cage seeing sharks on tv is nice
but seeing them up close in real life is
special
ride a camel in the desert this is an
experience you have to feel for yourself
or if you can't do it at least ride a
horse on the beach or
on a beautiful horse trail
buy one thing that is expensive and
leave it for your son or your daughter
when you pass away for example if you
have a son
buy an expensive watch and wear it a lot
so that it will be a lot more special
for your son just to have around
when you're not there anymore
pack and fly on the same day be
spontaneous pack a bag
head to the airport without knowing your
destination and then
when you get there choose where to go
and fly there
on the same day life is short
be adventurous
take some time out get off the grid you
know life can be sometimes so busy in
this
rat race that you never even have time
to just
relax and just live so shut yourself up
from the world
take a full day close the doors of your
house turn off the phone
and just relax and you don't even have
to get out of your pajamas
just take a 24 hour timeout and just
be you guys life is short
so don't waste it take some time off
just to tick off that
bucket list and if you need some reason
and motivation to actually
do it then check out this video here and
it's going to help you i'll see you
there
cheers guys